Y
estamos seguros si todos los pueblos que fueron
perjudicado
todos los derechos
imperio ruso si se unen
hay una posibilidad real de romper romper
la columna vertebral de este malicioso violador del pozo Oki
y luchadores de la faz de la tierra directos en pleno
este imperio y que todos los pueblos
se sintió libre y vivió libremente
[música]
y vinimos aquí para
El pueblo ucraniano y el mundo entero para demostrar
que no todos los chechenos soplan y respiran en la nuca
parte posterior de la cabeza a Kadyrov y no a todos los chechenos
estar de acuerdo con sus acciones y no todos
chechenos y
apoyo apoyo que aquí en
qué es
significado de nuestra visita
recibe sangre
el primero es
espectáculo
Caucásicos lo que Rusia está haciendo aquí
crimen que agresión contra ucrania
ella es completamente injustificada
la segunda es para limpiar el nombre
Chechenos que lo intentan
denigrar y rusia